las fronteras de Marruecos permanecerán
cerradas durante Navidad y Año Nuevo
algo que ha obligado a los viajeros a
cancelar sus planes un nuevo golpe para
el turismo después de 2 años de crisis
por la pandemia
de los hoteles han dejado de operar los
únicos que siguen funcionando son los
populares entre los clientes locales y
que acogen en seminarios
el turismo es la base de la economía
local ya me al final suele estar repleto
de visitantes en esta época del año
cuando no hay turistas en James no hay
nada solo algunos residentes locales de
Marrakech que están aquí a Chile que
todos los que trabajan aquí se ven
afectados por la crisis del turismo los
caballos son nuestra única fuente de
ingreso si la perdemos no tendríamos que
comer ahora estamos sin trabajo no hay
nadie y la prolongación de la frontera
podría ser el golpe definitivo para
muchos negocios